6 26 on your wednesday morning we'd like
to introduce you to the big squeeze's
cousin on the 95 5 15 you've been
talking for months about the nevada
department of transportation's
fixer-upper project on the freeway
between the spaghetti while in
charleston well now welcome to the
upgrade work on charleston itself around
the 95 5 15. so ndot's having another
one of those in-person public meetings a
week from today it's july 6. we're going
to go over the whole thing they're
talking about widening charleston around
the freeway adding turn lanes to get
onto the freeway from charleston lots of
other proposed improvements so the
meeting is going to be from four in the
afternoon until seven at the east las
vegas library that's bonanza between
eastern mojave now the virtual meeting
that started yesterday scheduled to
continue through the month of july we've
got all the links you could want in the
online version of this story on our
website when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something's driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8 news now dot com